مع قربي دخول الحربي عامها الثاني اختفى
الممثل الكوميدي زولياقا العاليه تماما
ليحل مكانه زعيم الحرب بل زمن الحرب
المتصلبه حيث اكدت صحيفه واشنطن بوست ان
العام الذي قضاها الرئيس الاوكراني في
الخنادق جعله اكثر صلابه التغير في شخصيه
حسب الصحيفه
ظهر منذ رفضه دعوه بيلاروسيا لمفاوضات
اخرى قائلا لن يكون هناك منسك ثلاثه كما
رفض عروضا بابعاده الى بر الامان وظهر
كعدو اكثر شراسه مما توقعته موسكو حقيقه
رئيس مكتب الرئاسه الاوكرانيه اندريه
على تغيير المحن للاشخاص لافتا في الوقت
نفسه الى كان دائما قويا واصبح اقوى وعشره
اعتبرت ان زيلينسكي ابقى على القضيه
الاوكرانيه حيه ببراعه ببراعه فنان محترف
من خلال القائه مئات الخطب مضيفه توصل لاح
لقناعه ان النصر هو الحل الوحيد مستبعدا
امكانيه السلام مع بوتين التي تمسك بها
حين تولى مهامه
[موسيقى]